yo estaba terminando de jugar al fútbol
con amigos y mi esposa me avisa que
rompió bolsa
en ese momento estábamos esperando
nuestro quinto hijo pero éste venía
distinto porque pesaba poquito estaba de
sólo seis meses y nacía ya así que
volamos al hospital con miles de cosas
en la cabeza por todo lo que podía pasar
y después de dos días
bravos nació juan bautista
con apenas 800 gramos un apetito
en ese momento se imaginarán mezcla de
alegría y de miedo prematuro incubadora
lleno de enfermeras y de médicos y mi
familia full porque había cuatro afuera
y nadie te daba garantías de nada porque
claro era muy chiquito
en ese momento no sabes cómo va a seguir
todo lo que sí sabíamos era que íbamos a
estar muy acompañados y que a él no le
iba a faltar nada iba a estar cuidado en
cada detalle y así fue hoy tiene
casi cuatro años y tira abajo las partes
de mi casa con sus pelotazos
creo que todos sabemos lo que necesita
un recién nacido pero creo que casi
nadie sabe lo que necesita alguien que
está en la otra punta de la vida alguien
que se está por morir
y de eso les vengo a hablar hoy tengo el
privilegio de trabajar hace 15 años como
médico acompañando a personas que están
en el final de su vida con una
enfermedad terminal esto se llama
cuidados paliativos y es el trabajo de
un equipo para cuidar como cualquiera de
nosotros querría y merecería ser cuidado
en un momento como ese
y cuando les hablo de personas con la
enfermedad terminal no se imaginen
viejitos nada más porque esto
lamentablemente toca todas las edades de
la vida laburantes recién casados
adolescentes deportistas si estás
haciendo la dieta de las harinas
fumadores no fumadores esto de una u
otra manera nos roza a todos y yo estoy
seguro que todos conocemos a alguien que
está luchando contra una enfermedad como
esta se me viene a la cabeza personas
que ahora estoy acompañando
gente que quizás ustedes conocen gente
que quizás está acá sentada como del
otro lado escuchándonos
y en honor a cada uno de ellos hoy
quiero y debo decirles que es muy
probable que mucha de esa gente esté
sufriendo injustificadamente
porque en nuestras sociedades sólo una
de cada diez personas recibe el cuidado
que corresponde para semejante momento y
esto es gravísimo
significa por ejemplo que allá afuera
hay gente con dolor pero no de esos
dolores que me torcí el tobillo me duele
la cabeza pasajeros dolor es de esos que
no te dejan dormir dolor que no te deja
pensar significa que hay gente con gran
incertidumbre porque no sabe cómo va su
tratamiento cómo sigue su enfermedad y
ven que se van poniendo flacos que ya no
pueden ir a trabajar y nadie les explica
lo que está pasando incertidumbre que a
veces te aguijonea más que cualquier
otro síntoma
hay gente que obviamente gente que
obviamente siente cosas está ansiosa
angustiada tiene miedo tiene dudas y
necesita ser escuchada y son poco
escuchados porque escuchar lleva tiempo
y gente que está girando por el sistema
y ojalá nunca les pase esto rebotando en
las guardias pidiendo ayuda en una
guardia yendo a otra porque acá no lo
ayudan y si llegan como sintiendo que
molestan
y vuelta a casa y nadie los quiere
internar
porque son pacientes que le generan
gastos al sistema y entonces quedan
fuera del sistema
yo creo que esto entre otras cosas pasa
porque nos cuesta hablar de la muerte
es un tema que nos da miedo nos paraliza
lo desconocido como será no estar más y
vemos películas con terapias intensivas
cables tubos
miedo al deterioro físico
esto de la chata el papagayo depender de
otros los otros días una señora me decía
a matías yo ya sé lo que tengo pero en
un momento sentí que el cuerpo se me
puso como viejo y tengo solo 52 años
entonces la consecuencia nefasta de todo
esto es que hoy hay gente falleciendo
anónimamente
sin despedirse sin organizarse a veces
sin saberlo
es un tema complicado no es un tema
cómodo para andar haciendo sociales no
es un tema sexy como dice un amigo amigo
juan
y esto es una parte importante del
problema la primera vez que fui a comer
a lo de mis suegros siempre me acuerdo
esa noche nos conocíamos en plena cena
me tira de lobos que trabajas en estos
cuidados paliativos muchos regalos para
el día del médico no te deben hacer
y ustedes saben a quienes les cuesta más
hablar de la muerte
a los médicos
somos un poco cómplices de mantener una
falsa expectativa
hemos recibido este mandato de curar
entonces este cuesta reconocer cuando ya
no poder resolver entonces agregas
tratamientos innecesarios
diluir las respuestas y de esto no se
habla y va pasando el tiempo un tiempo
que la vida de esa gente es precioso un
tiempo que es único así como cuando te
recibiste te casaste nació tu hijo
momentos de encuentro momentos clave
bueno este es el momento en el que se
cierra tu vida el último y hay que darle
el lugar que se merece
pero como esa última tarde de verano en
la playa que el mar está helado y hay un
viento cruzado que levanta la sombrilla
pero decir me meto anda saber cuando
vuelvo a tocar el mar uno acá pasa un
poco lo mismo es un tiempo para
aprovechar para para mirar de frente no
hay que quitarle a nadie la posibilidad
de que viva el final de su vida de que
protagonicé sus días de que tome sus
decisiones de que nadie decida por el
dónde y con quién quiero estar de que
disfrute con su gente sin dolor sin
síntomas de que pueda organizarse dejar
sus legados de que pueda acomodar su
alma de que sea quien escriba el final
de su propia biografía
y esto que suena medio novelesco es un
derecho que todos tenemos a vivir
dignamente hasta el final tengas la
enfermedad que tengas
hacer cuidados como ese bebé recién
nacido
y está bueno saberlo porque tenemos que
exigirlo
los cuidados paliativos existen hace
muchos años tenemos excelentes equipos
que están en los principales hospitales
de las grandes ciudades en las prepagas
que todavía no son muy conocidos cada
vez hay más y los que menos saben de
esto y por lo tanto más lo padecen son
los que menos tienen por eso allá por el
2009 con un grupo de amigos nos
propusimos generar algo distinto que
llegue más y mejor a la gente y fundamos
el host peace 'buen samaritano' una casa
para alojar a personas sin recursos y
con una enfermedad terminal en donde un
equipo de voluntarios además de médicos
enfermeras psicólogos nos hacemos
familia de esa gente que está al costado
de la vida y lo recibimos más que como
pacientes como wes 3
que lo que encuentran en la cabecera de
su cama es su nombre leo liliana ángel
josé y llegan de la nada agotadísimo
desconfiados doloridos y les aseguro que
acá empieza a cambiar la película porque
les preguntas quiénes son les alivia
esos dolores que traen hace meses
inexplicablemente les contás algo de lo
que está pasando y se dan cuenta que hay
gente que los va a ayudar que los quiere
cuidar que se quiere comprometer
realmente que va estar con ellos siempre
y entonces qué pasa recuperar las ganas
de comer vuelven a dormir una siesta lo
descubren que dios está con ellos en ese
momento más que nunca y vuelven a rezar
y recuperar la esperanza
y dejan de ser un diagnóstico para
volver a sentirse personas
y nos dimos cuenta que esto no necesita
ni grandes gastos ni grande tecnología
ni grandes instalación necesita gente
que se ponga en juego entonces empezamos
salimos de nuestra casa y empezamos a
ofrecerlo en hospitales públicos en
municipios a donde no solamente llevamos
atención y medicación sino también
cursos para que todo el mundo sepa de
qué se trata todo esto y lo que está
pasando es muy bueno miles de personas
están siendo acompañadas en esta etapa
especial de la vida cientos de
voluntarios están dando su tiempo para
ponerse en juego ahí equipos enteros de
médicos enfermeras psicólogos
trabajadores sociales están empezando a
entender y son capacidad instalada en
esos lugares y lo mejor todos nos dimos
cuenta que ya nadie tiene por qué sufrir
que esa famosa frase ya no hay nada más
para hacer es una de las grandes trampas
de la medicina
porque cuando vos ofreces un cuidado un
acompañamiento un alivio de los síntomas
profesional y humanizado la vida de la
gente de esta gente aunque se estén
yendo se transforma
y entonces nos encontramos con familias
que se reencuentran en ese momento y que
hablan naturalmente sobre lo que está
pasando y se van preparando hijos que
pasan tardes enteras con sus padres
y comparten y disfrutan mamás que hacen
su tarea
sus últimas tareas con sus hijos y son
capaces de dejar sus últimos consejos
gente que te agradece esto es
impresionante los otros días en el host
y es una mujer me decía matías
yo nunca me imaginé que le iba a decir
de nuevo papá a mi viejo
por esas cosas de la vida se habían
separado 15 años atrás y se estaban
volviendo a reencontrar en esta semana
tan especial
tan especial para ellos y para esos
nietos que conocieron a su abuelo y para
nosotros que fuimos parte de ese momento
entonces la verdad que yo decirles que
no hemos acompañado curaciones pero sí
profundas sanaciones personales y
familiares en esta etapa de la vida y
esto es poderoso
cada año que pasa me convenzo un poquito
más que esto no depende de médicos de
hospitales de enfermeras que si cada uno
de nosotros nos animamos un poco más a
hablar estos temas si pedimos la ayuda
adecuada cuando la necesitemos aquí hay
una gran oportunidad para que mucha
gente viva mejor para que muchas
familias esté mejor para que tengamos
una sociedad mejor
siempre me preguntan
vos que tenés cinco pibes y que tu casa
es un jardín de infantes y que tenés
este trabajo que es tan particular
qué significa para vos terminar bien un
día de trabajo
aunque sensación te quedas al final del
día
y lo que siento se parece un poco a lo
que me pasa cuando me acerco a sus camas
en esos últimos días de la vida
como en el caso de viviana
esta joven mujer de 44 años
que nos conocemos ya hace varios meses
que ahora está dormida
con una respiración superficial
con algunas pausas pero tranquila
con su marido al lado como siempre
los saludo con la mirada
los dos sabemos que falta poco
apenas está con un suero con un poco de
morfina para no tener dolor ni falta de
aire
la foto de sus 3 varoncitos la luz de
sus ojos
y me acerco un poco más
y le tomó la mano
y en ese momento como un rayo rememoró
todo lo que compartimos lo que charlamos
su sonrisa su mirada
sus deseos
su carácter
que era mujer me emociona pensar en ella
y le tomó el pulso
que apenas se siente
y pasan unos minutos
largos
y ya no tiene pulso
y dejó de respirar
recién estaba acá
y ahora ya no está
misterioso segundo en el que siento que
el cielo y la tierra se tocan
mientras ella se va
serenamente en paz